bonjour Sylvain merci beaucoup d'être
notre invité politique ce matin député
de Paris vice-président du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice wesser
Redon du groupe Ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France bonjour
Fabrice bonjour
on va évidemment commencer en parlant de
l'actualité et d'Annecy après l'émotion
après l'attaque au couteau le temps des
questions et des questions dans le débat
politique vous les avez entendu ces
derniers jours ces dernières heures
autour de la politique migratoire est-ce
qu'il faut réformer le droit d'asile
pour vous Sylvain Maya d'abord
évidemment mes pensées pour pour ses
enfants pour tout pour tous aussi le
les services de secours les policiers
qui sont intervenus extrêmement
rapidement pour tous ceux qui seront qui
ont confié en sorte que ça puisse
arrêter le plus rapidement possible
évidemment il faut toujours le rappeler
je crois que aussi beaucoup de Français
ont découvert les difficultés et la
complexité du droit d'asile
rappeler que
ce migrant était dans son droit c'est le
droit d'asile à l'heure actuelle en
France où en Europe
exactement et surtout il a fait une
demande en France qui a été c'est vrai
il a été débouté d'une première demande
mais il avait encore
un peu de temps pour pouvoir faire appel
et donc ça c'est important de le
rappeler est-ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin est-ce qu'il faut faire en sorte de
rendre les choses plus lisibles plus
simples avec des réponses plus rapides
probablement
moi je me garde toujours de faire des
réponses rapides souvent le droit
d'asile c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est fondamental chez nous il faut un
peu de temps pour pouvoir étudier chaque
demande et chaque demande en France doit
être aiguë de façon construite
proposé par certains est-ce qu'il faut
étudier les demandes d'asile en dehors
du territoire national voir dans les
pays d'origine des migrants vous savez
un demandeur d'asile qui arrive qui fuit
son pays parce que c'est la guerre parce
que il est persécuté va pas s'arrêter au
consulat ou autre spots que nous
pourrions avoir quelque part sur son sur
le passage vers la France donc moi je
suis je pense que on peut
vous avez raison mais on a aussi des
demandeurs d'asile de pays en guerre et
ainsi rien fait partie des ces pays
extrêmement difficiles il y a des
Libyens il y a des Afghans c'est aussi
une grosse partie des demandeurs d'asile
à l'heure actuelle donc au fond leur
demander d'attendre dans leur pays
national vous avez entendu Sébastien
Chenu hier et dit la série n'est plus
impayée En guerre il faut pouvoir
écouter je pense que il devrait aller en
Syrie voir un peu comment ça se passe et
je crois pas que des Syriens qui se
sentent menacés pour plein de raisons
puissent attendre des mois et des mois
tranquillement
en passant en allant vers un consulat
ouvert un hotspot français avant de
partir c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe vous prenez vos affaires vous
enfuyez c'est comme ça la réalité et
donc nous il faut accompagner cette
réalité étudier les dossiers ceux qui
ont le droit d'asile doivent pouvoir
rester en France que ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à rester en France doivent
repartir c'est aussi ça que nous pose
comme question pas parce qu'il y a un
problème avec les pays d'accueil qui ne
veulent pas les reprendre
ils sont en guerre c'est vrai que nous
ne nous renvoyons pas les les demandeurs
d'asile déboutés
en Syrie on ne renvoie pas en
Afghanistan par exemple
bien sûr ça c'est un autre souci sur les
auqtf comment faire en sorte que ce soit
mieux réalisé quand on a on est en bras
de fer avec de l'Algérie avec le Maroc
depuis plusieurs années ça s'est
amélioré quand on les empêche eux-mêmes
d'avoir accès au visa en rétention du
fait que on ne puisse pas à nous
renvoyer leur ressenti leur ressenti
sans qui n'ont pas vocation reste en
France et ben là c'est des bras de fer
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne mais on
ne peut pas renvoyer quelqu'un si le
pays d'accueil ne laisse pas laisser
passer c'est l'un des points sans trop
de la polémique avec notamment la droite
et l'extrême droite sur cette question
du droit d'asile que ce que je viens de
citer demande de recentrer sur les pays
en guerre et exclusivement les pays en
guerre pour en revenir à un droit
d'asile d'origine on s'est trop éloigné
de cette notion de droit d'asile en
France je crois pas je ne crois pas
d'ailleurs les chiffres n'explosent pas
des demandeurs d'asile quand vous êtes
d'une minorité persécutée dans votre
pays je pense par exemple à
l'homosexualité qui peut être une
persécution dans bon nombre de pays
est-ce que vous avez une possibilité
d'avoir un en France bah oui et c'est
pas forcément dans un pays en guerre
tout simplement parce que vous êtes une
minorité persécutée dans votre pays je
crois qu'il faut le garder ce droit
d'asile ça me semble important le
nombre de
ressortis d'étrangers qui viennent
s'installer en France qui demande le
droit de s'installer en France les
demandeurs d'asile c'est pas le le gros
du du bataillon donc je crois qu'il faut
garder ce droit d'asile cette main
ouverte c'est la France c'est notre
message de faire en sorte que ceux qui
sont persécutés ceux qui fuient la
guerre qui fuit
l'impossibilité de vivre dans leur pays
pour des risques eux-mêmes de sur leur
vie puisse pouvoir avoir en vocation à
venir s'installer en France alors
Elisabeth borne a dit on n'a pas attendu
cette attaque à Annecy pour s'occuper de
la question de l'immigration est-ce
qu'il y aura bien un projet de loi qui
sera présenté en Conseil des ministres
en juillet le ministre Darmanin
travaille dessus faire en sorte de
trouver un équilibre et une majorité
vous l'accompagnons nous l'accompagnons
on travaille à l'heure actuelle de voir
si on peut trouver une majorité autour
de la majorité présidentielle pour avoir
suffisamment de députés sur un texte qui
nous semble non seulement efficace sur
sa sur ce pour justement faire en sorte
que les occultés F soit mieux exécutés
on puisse renvoyer plus moins
difficilement les personnes qui n'ont
pas vocation à en France mais aussi
qu'on accueille mieux ceux qui ceux qui
travaillent par exemple sont essentielle
aucune entreprise en France aucun
service public ne fonctionne s'il y a
pas d'étrangers c'est la réalité à
l'heure actuelle comment on fait pour
mieux les accueillir parce que c'est
aussi eux qui font fonctionner notre
économie mais comment vous faites alors
vous discutez Gérald Darmanin discute
mais est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir
trouver un texte commun avec les
républicains ils ont leurs liens rouge
vous avez les vôtres ce ne sont pas les
mêmes Intex
un moment il faut être quand il y a un
texte et c'est pour ça que nous disons
maintenant il faut il va falloir y aller
parce que quand on a un texte c'est plus
difficile de parler de parler uniquement
dans le dans le vague de de grands
principes c'est est-ce que vous voulez
améliorer le retour dans les pays des
obligations de quitter le territoire le
qtf oui ou non quand on m'a demandé ça
aux républicains ils vont dire bah non
on attend un texte extraordinaire le
texte que nous nous voudrions porter
alors qu'on a pas de majorité je crois
qu'à un moment il faut être réaliste sur
les choses
et c'est pour ça que là c'est pour ça
que maman on est face aux Français
disons est-ce qu'on a envie d'améliorer
la situation oui ou non c'est ça la
question
pareil pour la gauche c'est à dire qu'il
faudra aller chercher aussi des voix à
gauche et leur dire est-ce que tous ceux
qui sont en train de travailler qui sont
en première ligne deuxième ligne en
France qui n'ont pas pour plein de
raisons difficultés d'avoir des papiers
définitifs ou bien qui n'ont pas
renouvelé leurs papiers on sait que
c'est il y a beaucoup de difficultés
pour renouveler leurs papiers leur
autorisation de travail est-ce que au
fond vous voulez qu'il reste dans cette
situation où ils sont on ne peut pas les
renvoyer ils ont des difficultés pour
travailler vraiment à trouver un
équilibre moi je crois que vous croyez
vraiment que vous pouvez trouver des
voies à gauche sur ce sujet aussi que
suivant qui est l'immigration
je pense je pense qu'à un moment il y a
un principe pour chaque député c'est
d'être en action et de faire en sorte
que son mandat c'est 5 ans qui passe
c'est pas que de la protestation c'est
de pouvoir améliorer la vie des gens
combien viennent nous voir on nous
demandant de de les aider viennent voir
qui a eu l'occasion de d'en parler
dessus en disant bah écoute j'ai tel ou
tel dossier où ils ont tout à fait
raison il faut accompagner ces dossiers
là bah là nous proposons une solution
c'est de faire en sorte que ce qui
travaille
quelqu'un de refuser ces titres de ces
gens que les métiers je parle de d'un
spectre plus large y compris à gauche en
disant il faut qu'on
accompagnements
nous on a besoin qu'il vote un texte
global et donc il faudra aussi dire bah
il y a des vrais avancées sur ce texte
là peut-être d'autres points qui nous
plaisent moins mais on a besoin
d'avancer donc on va avoir voulu faire
durant même temps est-ce qu'elle va
vouloir faire du en même temps vous
n'allez pas perdre tout le monde
et ne pas réussir à aboutir à une
majorité on a bien compris avec le texte
des retraites que discuter avec les
républicains c'est pas un bloc donc donc
ce qu'il nous faut c'est nous recentrer
sur ce que nous sommes la majorité
présidentielle et aller chercher des
députés autour de nos utiliser
oui mais vous savez au début du texte
sur les retraites il s'affiche avec ma
bloc aussi donc
l'expérience
l'expérience montre qu'il faut avancer
nous sur les idées d'aller convaincre
députés par député c'est notre travail
nous aussi à l'assemblée de voir de
montrer tout ce qui est positif
peut-être de l'enrichir ce texte là mais
de garder ces deux pieds c'est-à-dire
être plus ouvert avec ceux qui ont
vocation assez en France et être plus
ferme avec ceux qui doivent partir
précisément vous êtes prêt à céder vous
avez vu les propositions des
républicains elles sont sur la table sur
quoi vous êtes prêt à aller dans leur
sens nous on continue à discuter c'est
difficile de faire sur un plateau parce
que l'expérience montre aussi que quand
on quand on avance sur tel ou tel point
il faut aussi qu'à la fin on puisse se
serrer la main en disant qu'on vote
dessus donc nous avons beaucoup avancé
sur le texte retraite sur sur des points
qui étaient importants pour eux puis à
la fin beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont pas
voté donc discutons de trouver un
équilibre pareil avec la gauche de ce
que nous mais sur nos propositions nous
on a une majorité sur en tout cas la
majorité présidentielle elle est ancrée
sur ce texte là pour nous c'est ce texte
là qui nous semble le bon équilibre être
plus ferme avec ceux qui ont pas
vocation à rester en France et plus
accueillant avec ceux qui travaillent et
font tourner notre économie donc c'est
soit Isra
Élien il y a pas de majorité
aux mains à marge d'un côté de l'autre
mais non mais parce qu'il y a un
équilibre vous savez pour pouvoir
parfois gagner 20 députés d'un côté vous
en perdez 20 dans la majorité donc il
faut trouver un texte équilibre je crois
que c'est celui que nous avons quel
était le sens de l'e-mail qui a été
envoyé samedi je crois vous avez dû le
recevoir invitant votre majorité
présidentielle faut-il ou non travailler
avec les républicains dans l'éventualité
notamment de armaniments au groupement a
toujours porté depuis qu'il a pris la
tête de renaissance l'idée d'être plus
en prospective et de pouvoir réfléchir à
quel pouvait être non seulement les
grandes idées que nous voulions porter
plus en amont souvent que le travail
gouvernemental travaille au
parlementaire et et pouvoir réfléchir
sur la vie la vie politique française
avec vous c'est une vraie invitation
pour pour regarder ce qui est possible
et et nos militants au fond ce qu'il
souhaite moi je crois que c'est
important on a des militants qui
cotisent c'est nouveau c'est cette année
donc c'est quelque chose d'important qui
puisse dire voilà nous on est prêt nous
on pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
trouver un équilibre d'aller de
travailler avec les républicains ou
peut-être certains d'entre eux et
peut-être majorité je n'en sais rien
dirons bah non nous nous souhaitons
garder notre indépendance et vous voulez
mais moi je pense que c'est toujours
plus facile d'avoir une coalition pour
pouvoir travailler parce que on a des
textes plus simples à voter mais je le
dis je trouve ça extrêmement difficile
moi qui qui suit tous les jours à
l'Assemblée nationale de trouver à
l'heure actuelle une majorité avec la
républicain à l'Assemblée
surtout très désunis entre eux donc il y
a plusieurs courants au sein et c'est
difficile d'avoir une unité vous savez
nous quand on décide quelque chose on
est
sans Renaissance on est 171 débuter on
peut avoir des frictions en interne on
peut discuter on peut se challenger il y
a une position qui a arrêté c'est la
nôtre et il y aura son soutien
sur le texte que que porte de Gérald
Darmanin oui vous avez les 171 députés
qui sont là par contre si on commence à
partir sur d'autres orientations bah
vous pouvez aussi députés qui se sentent
moins concernés par le texte parfait
leur chef des républicains Richie
attends un geste fort du président de la
République sur cette question des
migration il demande à être reçu par le
Président de la République pour parler
de ce sujet Emmanuel Macron peut-il
doit-il le faire doit-il le recevoir
mais je sais pas si il y a des contacts
ou c'est organisé en tout cas
ce qui est certain c'est que les les
responsables politiques sont reçus en
permanence par Elisabeth borne par
Gérald Darmanin il y a eu beaucoup de
discussions de la République non mais je
l'entends un moment c'est aussi
discuter c'est il faut arriver avec des
une vraie envie de cons ou co-construire
si c'est uniquement pour faire une une
sortie de l'Elysée en disant que acté
d'une différence entre ce que c'est ce
que vous c'est ce que vous créez
les LR bon bah il y a pas vraiment
d'intérêt en règle générale c'est on
discute en amont et on arrive à un
accord et pourquoi pas à ce moment-là on
va on va dire
un moment de l'attaque d'Annecy les
député vous étiez en train d'examiner la
proposition de loi du groupe pilote qui
visait à abroger la retraite à 74 ans et
au moment où on a appris l'attaque
Aurore berger votre président de groupe
est sorti pour dénoncer du coup la
teneur des débats questionnait dans
l'hémicycle et dire que du coup ça
n'avait pas lieu d'être étant donné ce
qui se passait à NCS qui a pas eu de sa
part une instrumentalisation politique
de ce drame vous savez j'étais juste à
côté d'elle au moment elle a pris la
parole et on avait l'ensemble des
députés de la majorité de Haute-Savoie
qui était donc entre la gare manque
était à côté de nous dans une émotion
extrêmement forte puisque nous venions
de l'apprendre nous cherchions des
informations et nous sommes allés et
Aurore berger et notre groupe est allé
devant les micros vous savez on était
déjà vraiment sous le choc donc
j'entends l'instrumentalisation
j'entends sentiment qu'on a que j'ai pu
voir sur les réseaux sociaux qui a été
largement porté par la France insoumise
vous savez on était en train d'organiser
fait une erreur je vais vous dire on
nous étions en train d'organiser juste
avant de prendre le micro comment faire
pour que nos députés puissent partir le
plus vite possible sur place c'est très
concret et nous étions obsédé leur dire
il faut absolument qu'il soit sur place
pour pouvoir au plus vite et quel est le
chemin le plus rapide et donc on était
toute une petite équipe autour d'eux
dont Aurore berger et dont moi-même et
on essayait de trouver des solutions
donc il y a pas eu de discussion de
instrumentaliser vous savez le texte
était déjà mort
le texte de liotte qui était un texte
une arnaque coûte comme politique qui
était déjà mort dans le à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc ça devait totalement
grotesque de de de continuer à discuter
de ça au fond il était temps que nous
nous rassemblions tous pour trouver des
solutions et une réponse à cet acte de
barbario nous n'avions pas beaucoup
d'informations à ce moment-là vous ne
regrettez pas vous avez fait la manière
dont vous avez fait
pas regretté si l'interprétation
l'interprétation est différent enfin
vous voyez je suis toujours un peu
embêté par rapport à un message qu'on
veut porter vers l'extérieur est-ce
qu'il a été mal compris j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que nous étions aussi pris par
l'émotion avec nos députés le député de
Haute-Savoie le député d'Annecy qui
était avec nous et qui était vous l'avez
vu d'ailleurs dans les micros qui
étaient extrêmement affectés nous étions
avec lui tout le temps
Sébastien Chenu parce qu'on va parler de
la réforme des retraites disait hier il
était invité du Grand Jury que vous avez
peur du vote vous avez peur des députés
vous avez peur des Français est-ce que
c'est fait ne lui donnent pas raison
écoutez il y a eu une loi qui a été
promulguée on a déjà une loi qui était
pour une majorité française qui n'était
pas favorable cette loi on le sait que
c'était compliqué on l'a porté pendant
les élections législatives l'élection
présidentielle nous savions nous pensons
que cette loi est essentielle elle a
déjà été promulguée et décrets
d'applications sont déjà publiés elle
s'appliquera à partir du 1er septembre
d'ailleurs il y a une revalorisation des
petites pensions des cette année donc
nous en sommes fiers aussi de porter ça
ensuite il y a un coup de comme
politique de l'iode et dehors orchestrée
par le rassemblement national et et la
France insoumise d'ailleurs c'est très
baroque c'est un peu les
le compagnonnage de de la rébellion du
populisme le front populiste comme
comment les appelle et qui nous qui nous
ramène dessus sur un sur un texte qui
est déjà qui est déjà passé et au fond
quand vous allez sur le terrain
mais personne ne vous en parle personne
et depuis bien longtemps vos collègues
journaliste qui me disait mais non j'y
venez avec nous ils sont allés faire des
tractages avec nous ils ont bien vu ça
veut pas dire que les gens ça veut pas
dire que les Français se disent que
c'est une que c'est une réforme
populaire ce n'est pas vrai dire comme
toutes les réformes des retraites mais
ils sont déjà passés à autre chose il y
a d'autres sujets qui alors actuels les
inquiète énormément ou là où nous sommes
interrogés au quotidien tout le temps
depuis un bouton d'ailleurs le pouvoir
d'achat à l'heure actuelle on a beaucoup
de questions sur le parcoursup les les
parents d'élèves sont toujours inquiets
à ce moment-là de l'année sur quelle
sera l'affectation de mon enfant on a on
a on a d'autres questions en permanence
forme de retraite ces chapitres clos
mais oui elle est passée depuis bien
longtemps depuis bien longtemps ça veut
pas dire que encore une fois ça veut pas
dire que les populaires elle est juste
les gens ont accepté en disant c'est
ainsi et au fond il y aura il y aura il
faut il faut il faut écouter dans tous
les pays d'Europe ça se passe comme ça
il faut travailler un peu plus on nous
avons une démographie qui est ainsi
faite il nous faut travailler un peu
plus pour garantir nos pensions et qu'un
jour nous semaine nous serons à la
retraite et nous serons contents d'avoir
une pension qui nous permette de vivre
et quel que soit le mode qui a été
utilisé c'est à dire 49-3 il faudra
peut-être réutiliser pour des migrations
alors il y a eu des votes il y a eu des
votes et la loi était promulguée il y a
une constitution nous nous souhaitions
voter c'est qu'à un moment
ce sont des migrations si vous êtes dans
la même situation il faudra utiliser la
même méthode mais moi mon objectif c'est
de porter un texte qui va changer la vie
des Français qui améliore la vie des
Français et pas de savoir quel
la façon ça va être votée c'est mon
obsession elle est pas là-dessus c'est
comment trouver un texte d'équilibre qui
soit efficace
faire en sorte que les occultés
repartent effectivement du pays et que
ceux qui ont vocation est resté puissent
y rester c'est ça c'est trouver un texte
qui fonctionne pas spécialiste je suis
pas un constitutionnalisme mon objectif
c'est de pouvoir promulguer les lois et
la discussion sur la retraite c'est
savoir est-ce qu'il fallait faire cette
réforme oui ou non c'est ça la
discussion qu'on a eu au dernier moment
oui pour nous c'est essentiel si on veut
garantir les retraites à l'avenir il
nous faut travailler un peu plus il y a
une notion de censure qui va être
discuter à l'Assemblée nationale cet
après-midi c'est la 17e en un an est-ce
que vous pouvez ne pas en tenir compte
est-ce que vous allez tenir 4 ans comme
ça nous on sera là et on va écouter les
différents discours tout à l'heure
vous l'avez dit c'est la 17 c'est la 17e
vous voyez qu'il y a un côté un peu
non raisonnable de ce que fait la gauche
au fond c'est de sortir en permanence de
d'hystériser l'Assemblée nationale 17
motions de censure 16 ont déjà échoué et
donc la 17e et puis il y en aura combien
18 et bien sûr il y a pas il y a pas de
majorité il le savent très bien c'est
histoire d'être toujours là de montrer
d'essayer de vouloir montrer qu'on se
sont eux et la France insoumise les
meilleurs
combattants face au gouvernement on voit
bien qu'il y a un jeu de posture
d'ailleurs depuis le début depuis cette
niche liotte c'est un jeu de posture jeu
de dupe
un mode politique Marlène Schiappa sera
auditionné mercredi matin ici au Sénat
par la commission d'enquête sénatoriale
sur le fond Marianne la semaine dernière
on a appris qu'elle aurait bloqué une
subvention à SOS Racisme est-ce que sa
nuit à l'image du gouvernement et de la
macronie j'ai pas plus d'informations
que ce que vous me dites il y a une
enquête qui est ouverte dessus il y a
pas viendra à répondre aux questions et
je suis certain qu'elle donnera
l'ensemble des réponses au sénateur
c'est une commission d'enquête c'est
important de pouvoir y répondre moi-même
qui fait partie de commission d'enquête
c'est à quel point c'est important
d'être très précis sur sur les termes
cette commission d'enquête faudra se
poser la question de ce maintien au
gouvernement
je sais rien c'est pas moi de décider
c'est au présent de la République
première ministre de décider moi Marlène
Schiappa et une ministre engagée elle
fait son travail toujours été à la
pointe de beaucoup de combat
qu'elle a bloqué la subvention SAS
raciste mais est-ce que c'est un
problème est-ce qu'elle peut se
maintenir au gouvernement il peut y
avoir des choix politiques de dire
[Musique]
avec horizon
niveau national avec dans l'ensemble des
départements
du côté de la droite je souhaite qu'il y
ait une liste unie avec le modèle avec
horizon avec Renaissance qui porte à
Paris comme ailleurs les couleurs de la
majorité présidentielle on travaille
très bien au quotidien on travaille vous
savez on travaille très bien au
quotidien à l'Assemblée nationale ça
fonctionne bien mais oui mais il y a pas
il y a pas qu'à Paris où il y a vous
savez qu'il y a des discussions dans
tout dans tous les dans toute la France
en tout cas toutes les zones où il y a
des il y a un renouvellement qui sont
pas encore totalement actés il faut
trouver des équilibres mais oui il nous
faut partir tous ensemble et je pense
que les Français ont envie de ça aussi
c'est que la majorité présidentielle
elle vient unie parce que nous sommes
unis aussi à l'Assemblée nationale merci
merci à vous merci
merci d'avoir été avec